Here's a cast on that may not be
the prettiest, but it's closed and fast.
This is a Silver Reed 860 mid gauge
machine, and the setup would be similar to
other Singer / Studio / Silver Reed machines.
The cast on uses slip stitch.
Slip settings on the machine means needles
in working or B position do not knit
and the yarn passes under those needles.
Let's get started by pulling
a few needles all the way out.
With the carriage set for plain knitting,
the cam lever is on O,
the side levers are on the triangle,
pass the carriage a couple of times
and align the needles into B position.
End with the carriage on the right.
With your needle pusher,
pull every other needle to hold position
or D or all the way out,
keeping those alternate
needles in B position.
Set the carriage to slip
by engaging both the side levers
to the circle position
and set the cam lever to slip.
Thread your carriage and knit to the left.
Secure that tail with
a clip or a close pin.
Notice how there are loops over every
other needle, and the needles that were
in B position do not have loops.
Now, this may seem a bit counterintuitive,
but that's the way slip works.
With your carriage on the left,
pull the empty needles all the way out,
knit across, and notice that these
needles now also have loops.
Do this one more time.
Pull those first same set
of needles and knit left.
Then pull the alternate
needles and knit right.
Cancel slip by setting both side levers
to the triangle and the cam
lever to O for plain knitting.
Knit a few rows and take
a look at the edge.
Not too pretty, but it is stable and fast,
and it works great for scraping on.